che cazzo i capelli già oggi ma perché è
bello ma che vede i capelli che ci oggi
bravi mi sta piacendo sono molto belli
vado così a un matrimonio probabilmente
secondo me per come mi sono alzato
neanche con insetticida mi si mettono un
po tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video sono fa vigenti
ci siamo su juan knight frank thies 2 ma
che gioia incredibile ma che gira cazzo
giri è una cosa meravigliosa ragazzi
appena ho scoperto che hanno fatto il 2
io ho fatto salti di gioia per tutta la
casa infatti non so se si vede la mia
felicità in faccia bene cominciamo a
preferisca ma come che hanno fatto anche
un 2 di un salvai l'ant in sei ok va
bene non sopravvivere entro le 6 gr per
questo lo sappiamo ma che bello che è
ragazzi meraviglioso e parecchio carino
no veramente a che figo ci sono le [ __ ]
un cazzo perché tanto sarà bruttissimo
comunque la partenza ragazze tutt'altro
che meravigliosa proprio bella c'è
scritto muori
ma tua madre devo capire un attimo
allora cosa devo fare qui parte che
cesta musica che la possono anche
togliere perché mi chiami girano le
palle
[Musica]
ok cosa cazzo è successo lega bene non
ho capito un calmi calmi che non sto cup
cosa devo fare allora in giro c'è ciao
flauti come stai
io sono qui ok devo andare a giudizio
che cazzo successo a si scarica il
computer ma seriamente non sto capendo
un cazzo a si scarica al computer quindi
posso vedere le cose piano però c'è il
tizio che sta andando a sinistra mia
[ __ ] la [ __ ]
la [ __ ] proprio che buttare vabbè dai
e dai e che cribbio qualcos'altro magari
mandatemi anche gesù già che ci siete
non bellissimo complimenti e se non ama
ho capito tutto con che ragazzi fatemi
capire un attimo perché non ho capito
una mazza di niente di quello che ho
visto a c'è il gufo è questo abbiamo
capito che non è non è molto amichevole
vabbè poi stessi occhi che c'erano anche
nell'altro che non ho capito il
portatile si scarica in 0,3 secondi
quindi meraviglioso cioè quello semplice
da fare e ce franti che fa il [ __ ]
che mi arriva davanti ogni tanto e devo
spegnere le luci qualche bello che sei
luigi non devo far scaricare i computer
in poche parole perché sennò ciò nel
culo si è svegliato il gufo quando si
sveglia il gufo son cazzi questo l'ho
capito e non posso stare quello
esistente scusate giorno cos'è incoming
cosa cazzo era che la lava calmi piano
regalano capito niente che sta
succedendo
oddio ciao frankie tutto a posto ha
posto un cazzo aiuto no no no no no rega
vi prego vi prego non capì non sto
capendo difficile e più difficile
l'altro che cazzo fai noi goof regga il
buffo no no no no no no tanto sbatte
dice che botta dal limite quello che
loro ha dato sulla porta
va bene così io non so già che fate
state facendo amicizia col gufo stranzi
e più figo di fight night with friends
non lo so perché riga cos'è no al redman
di merda tu devi toglierti ma non posso
rimanere sempre così ah no perché sono
il gufo mi fa il culo perfetto che ho
capito
no no no no no quanto sei bello zio no
vabbè ma va ci da un dentista e prima o
poi te lo consiglio
mi stava ascoltando i ragazzi perché mi
è spuntata una chiazza nera sul muro che
cazzo succede un secondo solo che
capisco cosa cazzo ecco vorrei aiuto
cosa sta su call mi calmi tutti cosa
cazzo vuol dire pazienza 500 sta
scendendo lega vuol dire che mi saltando
sto stronzo fatemi capire ragazzi
[ __ ] vecchia troya lo sapete che
cazzo guardi bellissimo se un cazzo non
ti invita la mia festa che fa il
pagliaccio no è stato è stato figo è
stato veramente figo che non ho capito
un chiama cosa faccia il contatore cioè
mi devo accorgere io di quando chi sa
che botta scassato tutto ragazzo
scassato li mortacci del gufo di merda
beh non si sono con file nights freddy's
mi è successo di dis cassarla
ringraziando iddio sono ancora intatte
va bene così bellissimo ragazzi ma
alquanto figo sto gioco da una 200 credo
su due o tre la cosa difficile rega che
ci sono migliaia di semplici pomelo
queste guancia ma da te ne mangio il
computer server soltanto per guardare si
stronzi e basta perché sennò col cazzo
dato che cosa me ne frega non capisco
quando arrivano adesso l'ho capito però
l'ho fatto in tempo quindi ok ho
convinto che mi spunta quello che sembra
march merlo non convintissimo proprio le
canzoni sono qua tutti e due perfetti no
basta regime il bello è che mi chiede se
vuole se vuole che mi spunti e devo solo
cliccare cancello non è difficile a
evitarlo credo e poi magari muoio 20
volte per ok chi siete ragazzi cioè che
figo che sei
no no no lega da dove arrivava lo aperte
lo aperte cazzo la ventola non volevo ho
sbagliato ho sbagliato io non so se si
era capito ma sono un [ __ ]
ho avuto un momento di panico perché non
avevo capito quale delle due fosse
ovviamente ho azzeccato quella sbagliata
ma è ovvio mi va beh strano ho già posta
perché c'è freddi sul muro a caso non
avevo nemmeno notato perché mica il
gioco è talmente incasinato che non ti
fa vedere un cazzo ragazzi no no no ho
detto no kat
clampi rega impossibile ah eccolo qui
che non lo vedevo più fantastico stato
bellissimo il quadro dietro che uguale
il gufo il gufo di merda il gruppo
rimane te lo fai così sempre quasi
sempre a parte quando si sveglia quello
stronzo del pagliare da una [ __ ] che
caga sono creativa appello del 7 levi
dai [ __ ] grazie alle animazioni sto
gioco non ho mai visto un file naito one
night con le animazioni vere di gente
che cammina a cielo sono in filenet 3
tipo broken o no ecco lo sapevo
no no mi chiami sono salvato sto gufo
dovete uccidere abbattetelo cazzo il
problema è che geniale e sto gioco
perché sa guardare il ragazzo di gufo
devo tenere le luci accese quindi un
macello che questo scatto di compiuta si
scarica come niente mi chiama che
batteria cia pali cinesi neanche dei
cinesi guardano guardò sarà il filato
tutto nel culo ragazzi ce l'ho fatta
parte c'è una coca cola what perchè chi
è che si è sgolato la coca siamo alle 3
di notte ragazzi e ce la sto facendo
cosa impossibile nella vita non ci posso
credere manco io non dovevo dire questa
cosa che non dovevo dirlo perfetto
grazie di ricordarmi ogni volta che devo
starmene zitto perché questa è la
risposta redman dai cazzo scattate se 4
di notte ma edizione che non ne posso
più un'ansia il bello che sto stronzo c
spunta come niente mentre franti almeno
un po di tempo te lo da è chiuso è
chiuso e ciò che ai cani
luca ha posto fatto fatto fatto si è un
attimo però cazzo troppa roba insieme
calimici che mi piano sto capendo più
niente redman t'ammazzo col pomodoro che
ci ha attaccato al muro dello giuro era
è una roba indecente sto gioco una roba
veramente in concepiti casa che
inventato sta roba cioè fatemi capire
che problemi mentali ha per attaccare
quello di winnie the pooh che non dicono
mai il nome
ok ok possa accendere non possa
accendere mi sa che non posso accendere
cioè con questa l'avete anche gesù nel
repertorio non lo so ma andate anche lui
grazie proprio non manca solo lui
proprio grazie mille molto gentili il
gufo lo sapevo è chiusa redman la cosa
ma basta piatta merda è solo come sono
vivo ai ragazzi sono le cinque cielo
stoffa ce la sto facendo non so come no
no eh vabbè che cazzo mi chiama un po
l'uso linz etici
vai via vai via di giunta lo spruzzo in
faccia ti ammazzo la famiglia pure sono
le cinque ragazzi sulle cinque forza
scattate se sei di merda per l'amor di
dio no no no donna cos'ha fatto
non so neanch'io
ti ammazzo ti ammazzo se perdo ti
ammazzo dai dai dai
perché no perché non scattano sta merda
di 6 forza all'inizio no no no no no non
rischio premio in un po perché lo
scatolone sei solo due ore di gioco dai
ti prego sono due ore che sono le cinque
ti prego ci credo non ci sto chiedendo
non ci sto credendo ho vinto ho vinto a
juan aitef l'unpli 2 al primo episodio
non ci sto che non è possibile ragazzi
ce l'ho fatta in una maniera incredibile
va bene così sono contento sono
soddisfatto tu puoi morire cos'è hard
boiled mode cioè una roba tipo di e
vabbè che cazzo succede
troppa roba insieme a è proprio così
frenetico dall'inizio meraviglioso
ragazzi non faccio la prossima volta
perché non ce la farò mai nella vita
che cazzo no vabbè troppa roba rega
impossibile questo è veramente
la vasca anche se cuffie la uccise oggi
le uccise va bene ragazzi è stato bello
così o per oggi concludo che mi so non
voglio finire in vittoria e basta perché
non ci posso fare quindi ragazzi
vittorie altri l'episodio non è mai
successo farò anche la hard boiled
questa cosa qua però non adesso perché
voglio vivere ancora c'è proprio ciò
questa voglia di vivere quindi lascio
perdere
spero che a video vi sia piaciuto a cava
seguito se video è piaciuto
l'accertamento mi piace anche la pagina
di facebook e co meno di video trovate
la descrizione forse dovresti
scheletrici vediamo le professioni e la
ragazza
[Musica]